in the opening scene a group of police
officers surround a residence and
apprehend a man with severe facial
blisters that EST stressed man attempts
to explain that there is something in
the water but the cops disregard him and
transport him away in their vehicle the
scene then shifts to 6 months later and
we are introduced to a farming family
living in Telico Plains Tennessee the
youngest son Zach is seen collecting cow
dong in the yard when his step brother
Cyrus playfully shoves him onto a dung
cart yeah this is how we have fun this
leads to a physical altercation between
the two but they are soon stopped by
their Stern and Pious stepfather Nathan
as Cyrus is his biological son Nathan
takes his side and beats up his stepson
for fighting just then Zach's sister
Alice summons all of them for breakfast
at the table Nathan recites his prayer
and begins eating while his wife Francis
has her Gaze fixated on their farmhand
Mike it appears that she is a crush on
him she wants Mike to go even further
down south a short while later a real
estate agent named Charlie Davidson who
is also the head of Chamber of Commerce
arrives there to buy the food grown on
their farm he talks to Francis and tries
to persuade her to sell their Farmland
however she dismisses him and sends him
away at night Francis visits her
children's rooms to kiss them good night
when she enters Zach's room she inquires
about the morning's incident Zach
confides in her and tells her that he is
fed up with Nathan's strictness in
response Francis advises him to show
respect to Nathan because he has
accepted them into his family later on
Francis pin in front of the mirror and
goes to bed with her husband hoping for
intimacy however Nathan stops her
abruptly and claims that it's a man's
job to initiate the process because he
used the word initiate the mood is
killed and they go to bed this saddens
her and she is unable to sleep
thereafter as a result she walks out and
sneaks into Mike's nearby Shack Mike
suddenly appears from from behind and
starts touching her Francis also gets
carried away and the two start getting
intimate now Mike knows how to initiate
meanwhile Nathan wakes up to the sound
of the window shuttering and finds his
wife missing as the weather worsens Zach
is also roused from his sleep looking
out the window he is shocked to witness
a large meteorite crashing onto their
property emitting an eerie glow Zach
rushes to seek help from their neighbor
Dr Alan Forbes informing him of the
incident Nathan also goes outside to
investigate and spots his wife coming
out of Mike's dwelling making him
realize that she's cheating on him
however he opts not to react and
proceeds toward the meteorite along with
his son upon closer examination they
find it to be a large sphere with a
tough outer shell Allan advises caution
and suggests waiting for an accurate
examination might not be a ball might be
a square the following morning Charlie
pays a visit to Allan at his Clinic to
talk about the mysterious meteorite when
Allan says that he wants to alert the
Environmental Protection Agency Charlie
attempts to dissuade him he fears that
his clients will not buy the land there
which would make him lose a lot of money
he encourages Allan to examine the
object by himself and figure out if
experts need to be involved following
this Allan Charlie and Nathan's families
gather around the meteorite for further
examination Allan strikes the meteorite
with a hammer causing a foul smelling
liquid to ooze out later in the day Alan
tells Charlie that he has conducted
numerous tests but is unsure about what
to look for hearing this Charlie
suggests leaving the object as it is and
avoiding involvement of authorities
Allan's wife Esther also manipulates him
to remain silent because talking about
it might decrease their property's value
at night the meteorite's hard shell once
again emits a glow and dissolves into a
luminous gel-like substance that seeps
into the oil Zach Witnesses this with a
astonishment and senses that something
is wrong the next morning Allan finds
that the meteorite has vanished he then
visits Nathan's home and theorizes that
the mysterious object was actually a
waste tank dropped from an airplane
hearing this everyone begins laughing
except for Zach who is sure that the
object was not just ordinary waste as
the situation calms down everyone gets
back to their work Nathan starts working
on his farm watering his crops and
feeding his livestock one day an
employee from the Tennessee Valley
Authority named Carl Willis arrives in
the town he is here to assess the land's
suitability for a new water reservoir
upon learning of his arrival Charlie
approaches him and offers assistance
with the project Carl however emphasizes
the confidential nature of his work and
the potential termination of the project
if any interference is detected by the
TVA despite this Charlie remains unfaced
and offers to drive him around the city
on the other hand Francis goes to pick
up some vegetables from the their Garden
for cooking to her surprise the
vegetables have grown exceptionally well
and are unusually large in size she
brushes it aside though assuming that
Mike must have just seated them with his
big old Willie she then selects some for
her meal preparation while cutting open
a large cabbage she is shocked to
discover that the inside is completely
rotten and inedible perplexed Francis
attempts to cut the tomatoes but brown
liquid suddenly squirts out of them on
her face I could keep going with the mic
jokes but I will stop here later while
dining Zach senses something wrong with
the food furthermore the well water is
cloudy and has an unpleasant taste Alice
also acknowledges the change in taste
but their Stern father forces them to
consume it that same night Zach who is
unwilling to drink the home water sneaks
into Allen's place and fills a bottle of
clean water for himself and for his
sister the following morning Nathan is
watering his crops and is delighted to
see their great growth he thanks God for
what he believes is a Bountiful Harvest
unaware of the reality just then he
hears the screaming voice of Cyrus
prompting him and Zach to rush towards
him they find that their pet horse has
become violent and is attacking Cyrus
scared they hurriedly help him out
through a barbed wire saving his life in
the afternoon Charlie stops by Nathan's
farm and again tries to convince him to
sell the property as usual Nathan
declines his request and showcases the
year's abundant Harvest he even offers
char a juicy looking Apple to taste it
Charlie takes a bite only to be
disgusted by the presence of worms
inside shocked Nathan cuts open a couple
more apples only to discover that it's
all rotten in the meantime Alice as
usual goes to the hen coup to feed the
chickens but this time she notices
something unusual as the hens exhibit
strange Behavior despite this she
proceeds to feed them not long after the
hen suddenly turn aggressive and attack
the young girl her screams reach her
father and brothers prompting them to
rush to her rescue Nathan carries Alice
back to the house while Zach notices a
cloudy liquid oozing from the dead hens
in the aftermath Dr Allen examines Alice
and provides her with some medication
during this he notices that Francis has
lost a lot of weight and looks very
unwell in addition she has developed a
large boil on her face that alters her
facial features concerned Allan suggests
she visit his clinic but she remains
silent silent fearing her strict husband
later in the evening the entire family
is sitting in the living room when
Francis starts behaving strangely
shortly after the family notices her
sewing her own hand to the socks which
causes bleeding Zach and Nathan attempt
to stop her but she violently pushes
them away eventually Cyrus and Nathan
manage to grab her and drag her to a
room worried by his mother's
deteriorating condition Zach rushes to
alen's place to seek assistance sensing
the urgency Alan grabs his medical kit
and hurries to their house however
Nathan and Cyrus act as if nothing
happened and ask the doctor to leave
after his departure Nathan slaps the boy
scolding him for dragging The Strangers
in their private matters while walking
back home Alan sees an unusual sight
steam rising from Nathan's well sensing
something am Miss he fetches a bottle
full of water as a sample to be analyzed
at a nearby laboratory the next day Carl
is seen surveying the local area for the
planned water reservoir during this he
feels thirsty so he goes to the nearby
Nathan's Farmhouse to get a glass of
water he knocks on the door only to find
that it's open Carl slowly enters the
kitchen and helps himself from the
kitchen faucet but just then he is
attacked and nearly killed by a mentally
unstable Francis fortunately Nathan
intervenes in the nick of time and sends
his wife to the room he then asks what
Carl is doing here but the ladder is so
scared that he forgets about his thirst
and runs away as the days pass francis's
health deteriorates and the blisters on
her face also increase she speaks
incoherently of things and eats in an
unsettling manner nevertheless Nathan
ignores all of it as he believes that
it's her punishment from God for her
infidelity Nathan and Cyrus also seem to
have started being infected by The
Poisoned food and water as scars begin
to appear on their faces in contrast
Zach manages to protect himself and
Alice from the infection by consuming
clean water and food obtained from
Allan's house one night Nathan sits
beside his wife whom he has tied to the
bed and reads her a few lines from the
Bible Thou shalt not tie thine loved one
to the I'm going to skip this part he
eventually falls asleep after which
Francis manages to break free from her
restraints meanwhile Zach awakens to the
strange noises and heads downstairs to
investigate there he is suddenly
confronted by his mother whose face is
now turned into a pus covered mask with
disheveled hair she has become so
violent that she starts attacking her
son with a fire poker the commotion
wakes up Nathan who then forcibly drags
and locks her in an underground bunker
Alice Witnesses all of this from the
stairs which makes her cry the following
day Allan visits the lab to obtain the
test results for the water sample the
lab assistant informs him that the water
contains an unidentified element which
is altering its metabolic properties and
molecular structure realizing the
potential threat Allan rushes to contact
Carl for assistance but he cannot reach
him meanwhile Charlie shows up at
Allen's house and seeks Esther's help in
convincing Nathan to sell their property
Esther agrees and the two head to
Nathan's Farmhouse only to be attacked
by infected dogs that have turned
violent in an attempt to save herself
Esther runs but she is caught and
fatally mauled by the dogs on the other
hand Charlie enters the bunker unaware
of the horrors awaiting him he is soon
attacked by a scary looking King Francis
who kills him and devours his flesh in
the evening Zach returns home with some
healthy food and clean water for his
sister after feeding her he decides to
check on his mother however before he
can do so he's confronted by his
stepfather who is now succumbed to the
infection as a result he starts
attacking Zach but the latter manages to
escape at the same time Alice hears a
noise outside her room she opens the
door only to be startled by Cyrus who
has also lost his sanity charges toward
the young girl but just as he's about to
harm her Zach walks in with a bat and
subdues his half brother following this
he hides Alice in a closet and Promises
to return with help at that moment Allan
arrives at the scene looking for the
children but tragically Nathan appears
from behind and Strikes him with a
hammer killing him on the spot Nathan
then Corners Zach one last time and is
about to kill him but just then Carl
comes to the rescue and stabs Nathan
with a pitchfork the chaos smoke begins
emerging from the basement and the house
starts to crumble Zach and Carl Rush
upstairs to retrieve Alice but are
confronted by the awakened Cyrus in an
act of self-defense Zach pushes Cyrus
off the stairs seemingly incapacitating
him after this Carl carries Alice and
rushes to his car while Zach looks for
his mother to his despair he finds his
mother's corpse dissolving into liquid
heartbroken Zach prepares to flee the
collapsing house but Nathan once again
can confronts him the boy manages to
dodge his attacks and impales the
Pitchfork deeper into his body before
making his way out right then Carl comes
back to Rescue Zach and the trio drives
away moments before the house collapses
several months later we see Carl who is
hospitalized because he also happened to
drink a small amount of the Farm's water
the man from the opening scene is
revealed to be none other than Carl who
suffered a nervous breakdown due to the
Infectious water before being
hospitalized the authorities in the news
reassure the public that the well
containing the poisonous water has been
destroyed and there is no longer any
danger to the people in the final scene
the ground and trees around the
Farmhouse begin to fall and break apart
revealing more of the Luminous liquid
spreading across the surface subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching